leadership has nothing to do with being
in charge I know many people who sit at
high levels in organizations who are not
leaders they have lots of authority and
we do as they tell us because they have
authority over us but we don't
necessarily trust them we wouldn't
follow them I mean I know people at low
levels of organizations who have no
formal Authority but they made the
choice to help the person to the left of
them and help the person to the right of
them and we would follow them anywhere
and that's basically what leadership is
it's the responsibility to see those
around us rise and one of the
opportunities for businesses is to teach
leadership when we're Junior in a
Company the company gives us lots and
lots and lots of training and we'll
teach how to use the computer systems
and we'll teach how to sell and if
they're good at the job we promote them
and eventually we promote them into a
position where they're responsible for
the people who do the job they used to
do but we don't teach them how to do
that we know we have to train people
when they're new so why don't we train
people when they're new leaders there
are skills that go along with leadership
like listening how to have difficult
conversations how to give and receive
feedback we should teach them and that's
way you that's the way you get good
leaders